abuja looks like a massive construction
site
as developers rush to meet the demand
for luxury homes
the kovid 19 pandemic has left millions
of people
out of work and struggling to pay bills
and put food on the table
but it has not stopped the property boom
in the city
thousands of new homes have been built
they are buyers with money to spend
nigeria is still growing and people are
coming into higher means every day and
everybody wants to have
a better house and a better location
with more amenities
and of course security nigeria's real
estate industry is not controlled or
regulated by laws
developers dictate the prices there's no
shortage of high-end apartments
for those who can pay cash or obtain
mortgages
houses on this estate cost about half a
million dollars
does not discourage buyers who sometimes
have to make down payment
months before the apartments are ready
very few people can afford these prices
in nigeria
where the monthly minimum wage is less
than a hundred dollars
joshua ardino and many nigerians like
him
don't have the money for luxury homes
and can only look at the properties on
the outskirts of the city
but they also pose problems there are so
many properties i would like to get
which i don't have in my house due to
the space that is not there 3d
infrastructure the building
some of them are getting old so some
things are not properly
you know the way they are supposed to be
it's estimated nigeria needs to build at
least
20 million more homes the government
says plans are in place
but it's not going to be easy if we have
to make
a big dent on the housing deficit
we probably ought to be building about a
million homes a year
so we are nowhere near that at the
moment
so we have set for ourselves as a
corporate objective
a target of doing 200 500 000 homes
the country is facing economic problems
and that makes
access to money for affordable housing
even more difficult
if we leave it alone to the private
sector it's not going to work because
already
we have double digit interest rate which
businesses cannot afford
that is where we need social
intervention programs
all the money that we borrow from abroad
is enough
to build housing and in millions
with house prices rising and
unemployment figures also going up
those on lower incomes may not have any
chance of seeing their dream home
for quite some time fidelis
al jazeera abuja